The Joe Rogan Experience can you please
tell us like what is the mechanism how
do statins work and what does it do to
lower cholesterol yeah
so for many years there's been this
misconception
the high cholesterol is one of the most
single one of the most important risk
factors for development heart disease so
I broke down the data and I've published
a lot on this stuff to look at it
properly and Joe this uh the the
association of uh cholesterol and heart
disease came from something called the
Framingham study which was in
Massachusetts started in 1948 carried on
for several decades where they followed
up 5 000 people and many risk factors
for heart disease came from that
correlations which were then validated
like things like type 2 diabetes and
high blood pressure even smoking and
high cholesterol
now what's interesting about Framingham
is when you look at the associations of
total cholesterol and heart disease it
was only there when your total
cholesterol the significant Association
was only there if it was over 300
milligrams per deciliter very few people
have total cholesterol that high and we
have to also understand that most of
your cholesterol is genetic eighty
percent of the cholesterol is genetic 80
80 since it's since I've because
cholesterol is a really important
molecule in the body it's not just a
it's you know important for maintaining
cell uh cell cell membranes it's
important role in the immune system
um hormones hormones vitamin D synthesis
all of that stuff right so it's genetic
you can alter it with your diet the
components of it something called
triglycerides and HDL so-called good
cholesterol right but so the total
cholesterol was not a very good
indicator so if it was very very high
there was Association but that's in
what's interesting about that is though
most almost all of those people had a
genetic condition which gave them very
very high levels of cholesterol it's
called familial hyperlipidemia affects
one into 250 people right and then at
the very other end from Framingham the
very low levels of cholesterol less than
150 milligrams of desolator or four
millimoles in in European terminology
there was almost no heart disease so
again there's genetic factors there and
so basically people with genetically low
cholesterol tend to not develop
premature heart disease
another interesting caveat most of that
data on the development heart disease
was only up to people who were 50 or 60.
and what wasn't publicized is that once
you hit 50 as your cholesterol dropped
in Framingham
your mortality rate increased never
really discussed so I looked at all of
this so that's interesting
but I think the thing that really
um sort of was a nail in the coffin for
me and understanding the association of
cholesterol and heart disease was very
weak
was William castelli who is one of the
co-directors of Framingham cardiologist
in 1996 did a full summary of Framingham
and he said this he said unless you
because you know you're going to talk
about you may be thinking okay hold on
there's good cholesterol and bad
cholesterol so he specifically focused
on what we call LDL bad cholesterol and
he said unless your LDL cholesterol is
above 7.8 millimoles per liter which is
something like
um
Joe it's probably a yeah at least 300
pretty much three around 300 milligrams
per deciliter it has no value in
isolation in predicting heart disease so
what they determined from framing them
was your risk of heart disease as one of
the risk factors was something was your
total cholesterol divided by your HDL
the good cluster or the ratio
so that's the first thing so the
association of cholesterol and heart
disease is quite weak first and foremost
the second question is
when you try and prove that there is a
biomarker that is causal in heart
disease you want to show that if you
lower it
then there is a difference in heart
attacks and strokes for example
and only in 2019
more recently
um I co-authored a paper in bmj
evidence-based medicine with two other
cardiologists and what we did was we
looked at all the drug trials at
lowering cholesterol
to find out is this true when you look
at in totality not cherry-picked
evidence is there a correlation with
lowering LDL cholesterol and total
cholesterol and preventing heart attacks
and strokes and this is based upon
randomized control trial data so this is
the most robust evidence you can get Joe
no clear correlation it was BS the whole
thing was BS in that sense like it's a
very weak if anything
so that means so then the next question
is well hold on how do statins work and
that's the question you asked me earlier
and it's a great question it's a really
important one statins do have a small
benefit but one of the properties of
statins which isn't talked about is they
have anti-inflammatory and anti-clotting
benefits so even though they lower LDL
cholesterol the real benefit in
preventing heart attacks and strokes is
through that mechanism but when you
break it down as I said before your risk
is you know the benefits are about one
percent if you're low risk of heart
disease but if you've had a heart attack
and many patients I see have had heart
attacks and they've got automatically
put on statins and that cardiologists
read even checked their cholesterol
because in the Cardiology Community we
kind of knew that was like it doesn't
matter what your cholesterol is let's
put them on a Statin because the trials
show there are benefits but what are
those benefits when you break them down
in absolute terms this is really crucial
and important and this isn't Cherry
Picked stuff this is what all the
evidence shows
and it's been peer reviewed Etc if
you've had a heart attack
patient comes to me Doc shall I carry on
the Statin or I've been put on the
Statin or I'm getting side effects I say
to listen let's just let me just explain
to you the benefits first so that you're
not you don't have an exaggerated fear
of stopping a Statin and you also don't
go around with the illusion of
protection thinking that's the only
thing I need to do now
over a five-year period if you take your
Statin religiously and don't get side
effects right because remember the
trials took out people with side effects
so best case scenario
your benefit of a Statin is 1 in 83 for
saving your life
right and 1 in 39 and preventing a
further heart attack
now a lot of people find that quite
underwhelming
another way of looking at the statistics
Joe and this is important for
populations
looking at those trials and when I when
I what I'm about to tell you when I talk
at conferences to doctors and general
practitioners and there's like a gasp
from the audience right when I tell them
this
and this is published in the bmj so in
the randomized trials you look at an
average
how much if I ask you that question
right you've had a heart attack let's
say for example and statins are one of
the most prescribed drugs are the you
know miracle cure whatever the one of
the most potent
um beneficial drugs in the history of
Medicine
if you take those uh if you take a
Statin for five years having had a heart
attack in that five-year period how much
would you think or hope it would add to
your life expectancy you've literally
survived a heart attack right and now
you've been given this pill which your
doctor is telling you this is you must
never stop this is going to save your
life how much would you hope it would
add to your life expectancy over a
five-year period over that period you
know we can increment 25 30 yeah okay so
a few years I've had a few years
actually yeah
you want the answer yes just over four
days
four days four days
maybe those are great days though well
no fair enough absolutely and you know
but but you know this is so and the
reason I'm mentioning that is when you
look back over the last few decades and
people talk about what has driven down
death rates from heart disease there's
this assumption it's been the mass
prescription of statins millions of
people taking statins but the evidence
suggests there's a separate analysis
done they looked in European countries
high risk and low-risk people of heart
disease over 12 years was there a
difference in was there a reduction in
heart disease death rates because of
statins and the answer was no
and that doesn't mean that the data is
fraudulent it's been misrepresented but
if you accept hc4 at a four day increase
right but these are in people who didn't
get side effects who were adherent to
statins and real world data tells us Joe
even people have had heart attacks maybe
50 of them will stop taking it just
within a few years mainly because of
side effects you can understand why that
hasn't had an impact on the population
but think about that this is one of the
most powerful
lucrative drugs in the history of
medicine and this is how
marginal
that's people out here how marginal the
benefits are now once this information
has been out there and it's been
published and you've had these talks and
people are aware of this what has been
the reaction and has there been any
change in how it's prescribed
so I then so after this publication the
bmj initially um and then I I you know I
had to
um get another job right so I lost that
job in that in that hospital I then
ended up working for free briefly in
another NHS Hospital Cardiology
Department that I work for free
doing one day a week
um because I had another role with
health policy which I'll come on to uh
you know that they were paying me some
money and I didn't want to stop seeing
patients so I was working for free in
one hospital for a year in a Cardiology
Department
um I uh in sort of March 2014.
the uh I got a phone call
in fact an email initially from the
editor of the British medical journal
and she said Aseem
um you know let's come let's have a
meeting I think I went to meet her and
she said uh there is a man called
Professor sir Rory Collins Professor
Rory Collins is probably considered in
the world the lead Statin researcher
it's Oxford University he got his
Knighthood from the queen because of his
work on steins
he has said that you need to retract
Abramson and malhotra's papers
because there is a significant error on
the side effect issue and this is going
to cause harm people are going to stop
their statins
and she said straight away no I'm not
going to retract it but we're very happy
if you would like to publish a you know
send a critique and we'll publish it but
for some reason he decided he didn't
want to do that so this back and forth
was going on and then out of the blue he
decides whether it was him or somebody
else to go to the Guardian newspaper and
I get a phone call
from the guardian and the BBC which
again was Headline News
that what Abramson
had done it became a new story front
page of the Guardian was so damaging in
terms of their error on the Statin side
effects issue that people will die
essentially this is uh almost as bad as
um they were trying to make parallels
with Andrew Wakefield and the whole
measlemonts rubella issue that happened
many many years ago that was the
scientist that lost his license because
he linked the MMR vaccine to autism
right so they were trying to create that
kind of frenzy and I'm like well this is
okay so I went on BBC and I stood my
ground and and and that I think put the
bmj under pressure
and then the next thing that happens is
I remember I was with my cousin in New
York I'll never forget this and I get an
email a press release from the bmj
which I knew was gonna you know and this
is to be honest it's it's an attack on
one's credibility
but the bmj then decided they were going
to send our articles for an independent
review uh whether or not they should be
retracted and I know Joe just to put
things in context here that's
potentially career destroying in the
sense that if my article got retracted
it got so much publicity
and and I genuinely believe what I said
was correct but it gets retracted then
your credibility is undermined pretty
much forever and your careers you know
it would be career destroying for me I'm
at the beginning of my career
so I was on trial essentially for two
months if you like and uh you know that
was it was tough it was very very tough
um there was a panel they convened they
asked me to you know send in responses
and then whatever else I didn't know
what was going to happen and then I
think it was August 2014 I remember it
broke the news and it was um you know I
got an email and basically uh the panel
had come back 6-0 unanimous in our favor
wow there was no call for attraction
because John Abramson went through a lot
during that period as well I know you
interviewed him yes and uh and we talked
and whatever else when that happened Joe
there were two things I could have done
one was wow this is like too much I
don't think I can handle this I'm just
gonna you know I'm gonna hide away and
just keep a low profile but I thought no
you know what this is about ethical
evidence-based Medical Practice there
were some corrections that needed to be
done some caveats that they added in to
into the papers around the side effects
issue so I carried on this campaign I
carried on publishing other journals
kept talking about transparent
communication ethical evidence-based
medicine Statin of a prescription there
are other things we can be doing in
terms of Lifestyle right which are going
to be more powerful you know whether
it's low carb Mediterranean diet
exercise so why are we not focusing our
attention there rather than just giving
people all these pills that they think
is going to protect them from heart
attacks and in most cases it doesn't
and in that journey and this went on for
a few years
this is where things got uh really
interesting so so there was to answer
your question yes there was a lot of
backlash it was tough there was a bit
smearing going on
um but I realized then you know as a
public health Advocate that uh
you've got to have a thick skin
and grow a rhinoceroside and those those
are the words from a man called Simon
Chapman Simon Chapman is a professor of
psychology in Australia he was
considered the lead campaigner in making
sure there was Tobacco Control in
Australia and he wrote a paper talking
about his 38-year career in public
health advocacy and gave 10 lessons on
one of those lessons is this
as soon as your work threatens an
industry or an ideological cabal you
will be attacked sometimes unrelentingly
and viciously so grow a rhinoceros hide
and I thought you know what I'm up for
it I'm up for it and so many more people
came out of the woodwork to support me
other doctors said you're right you know
and I I thought this is about truth and
transparency and about ethical medicine
and highlighting all the corruption and
the conflicts of interest one of the
things that Professor Collins it hadn't
been made apparent is his Department had
taken over 200 million pounds at Oxford
for doing research into statins from the
drug industry and they also kept the
data commercially confidential so most
of the Publications and guidelines that
are coming on statins were coming from
emanating from that department where no
one had been able to independently
verify the data and he is quoted in the
guardian saying only problematic side
effects and statins affect one in ten
thousand people
so I thought this is something this
doesn't this doesn't add up I think
these are biases conflicts of interest
I'm not saying that he was deliberately
malicious but I think there's a huge you
know conflict of interest there that is
clouding his judgment plus he's not a
clinician he doesn't see patients so
there's all of those things that I think
limit his ability to really look at the
evidence properly